problem number one in the number 2010 or
2010 the value represented by the digit
one is what fraction of the value
represented by the digit 2 so we have
the number 2010 or we could rewrite this
as 2000 plus zero hundreds plus ten plus
zero and they're saying the value
represented by the digit one well the
value represented by the digit one is
ten is what fraction of the value
represented by the digit two well the
digit 2 represents two thousand so the
fraction is going to be the ten divided
by what the two represents two thousand
the one represents ten the two
represents two thousand you get let's
see we can cancel out a zero right there
we get one over two hundred with this
which is choice B problem 2 if P is a
positive integer which of the following
must also be a positive integer let's
see choice a 1 minus P well if P was to
two is a positive integer then 1 minus 2
would be equal to minus 1 and this is
not a positive integer this is a
negative integer so it can be a 1 over P
well once again I'm just picking two at
random the positive integer if P is 2
then 1 over 2 is not a positive integer
so it can't be B let me cross that out
cross that out right there well I'm
going to keep running with my number 2
if it doesn't work for number 2 it's
definitely not gonna work for any
positive integer so if P is 2 right here
then the square root of 2 once again not
a positive integer and then finally P
squared well for 2 if I take P is equal
to 2 then P squared is equal to 4 and in
general if I take any positive integer
and I square it if I multiply it by
itself I'm just going to get another
it's definitely going to be positive and
it's definitely going to be an integer
so my choice is D next problem problem 3
let me switch
colors just for fun according to an
article in a financial journal a certain
company earned 3.85 name eysan did
writing I haven't selected that later
earned three point eight five million
dollars last year based on this report
of the company's yearly earnings a
person reading the article estimates
that the company earned an average of
approximately thirty thousand dollars a
month and they're saying estimates so we
don't do the exact math which of the
following statements best describes the
reasonableness of this estimate for the
company's average monthly earnings so
three point eight five million dollars
last year and they we want to be able to
estimate how many how many monthly
earnings so we want to divide three
point eight five million by twelve
months right that's this three point
eight five million a year and we want to
divide it by twelve we could do the
exact number but we could say hey you
know what this is pretty close to three
point six million the reason why I'm
picking three point six million is
because 36 is three times twelve so if
we do three point six million we could
say that this is approximately three
point six million divided by 12 which is
equal to what if this was 36 million
divided by twelve we would have three
million right but it's not 36 million
divided by twelve it's one tenth of that
it's three point six million divided by
twelve so it would be 0.3 0.3 and you
can put a zero out front point three
million per month or another way to
write 0.3 million is 300,000 per month
now someone estimated that they made
$30,000 per month so they were off they
were too low by a factor of 10 right you
would have to divide by this the actual
estimate the correct estimate by 10 to
get their estimate so their estimate is
too low by a factor of 10 that is choice
B another way you could have thought
about this is instead of writing
3.85 million you could have
that as three thousand eight hundred
fifty thousand divided by twelve or you
could have said well that's
approximately thirty six hundred
thousand divided by twelve and then you
said okay that's three hundred thousand
you've gotten the same answer which is
ten times more than their estimate or
their estimate was too low by a factor
of ten problem for the mean distance
from the earth to the Sun is
approximately 93 million miles or one
astronomical unit the mean distance from
Neptune to the Sun is approximately two
point seven nine four times ten to the
ninth miles what is the approximate mean
distance from Neptune to the Sun in
astronomical units so essentially we
want to divide the average distance of
Neptune to point seven nine four times
ten to the ninth miles divided by one
astronomical unit which is 93 93 million
when you write it like this it's kind of
hard to digest or see what's going on
but what we can do is write this guy
right here in scientific notation as
well so 93 93 million 93 million looks
like that we could say that this is nine
point three times 10 to the one two
three four five six seven power so now
this thing up here simplifies to two
point seven nine four times ten to the
ninth over nine point three nine point
three times ten to the seventh now we
could just divide this by the way my
brain works I would like instead of this
to be two point seven I would like this
to be twenty seven and the reason why I
would like this to be 27 is because we
have a nine down here then we could say
27 divided by nine is roughly equal to
three so we can rewrite the top part of
this we could rewrite this if we
multiply this part by ten we would have
to divide this part by ten in order to
not change the number we don't
to actually change the value of the
number so we get 27.9 four times ten to
the eighth right all I did is I
multiplied this part by ten and to
offset that I divided this part by ten
ten to the ninth divided by 10 is 10 to
the eighth divided by nine point three
times ten to the seventh and now you
could say hey look twenty seven point
nine four divided by nine point three
that's going to be approximately three
remember we're trying to try to find the
approximate mean distance we can
estimate a little bit and then 10 to the
eighth divided by 10 to the seventh you
could you could just you could just
subtract seven from eight on the
exponents and so that's times ten to the
one 10 to the eight divided by ten to
seven is exactly ten times 10 to the 7
so our approximate answer is going to be
three times 10 to the 1 or 3 times 10 or
approximately equal to 30 astronomical
units and that is choice a